hi in this video I will talk about the
mechanism of cholera toxin and how
cholera toxin interacts with g-protein
signaling caused a huge amount of sweet
loss from the body
now cholera is caused by the bacterium
vibrio cholerae and it results in huge
amount of fluid loss diarrhea vomiting
and dehydration
now cholera gets transmitted by mainly
by water which is contaminated with
fecal matter or anything so the Vibrio
cholerae infects the intestinal
epithelial cells intestinal epithelial
cells has chain one ganglia side
receptors which actually binds to the
cholera toxin and cholera toxin falls
under the classical category of a B top
C it has two subunits once a B toxin
binds to the gm1 receptor on the surface
of intestinal epithelial cell it gets
internalized and normally this heavy
toxin interferes with g-protein
signaling normally g-protein signaling
is activated when G alpha subunits get
dissociated from the G beta and gamma
and activates adnan of cycles and this
results in conversion of ATP to cyclic
GMP and thus downstream signaling
cascade goes on and on what cholera
toxin does is the a subunit of the
cholera toxin does a specific type of
modification on G alpha subunit which is
adp ribosylation the cholera toxin takes
adp-ribose group from nad and put it
onto the G alpha subunit and as a result
the G alpha subunit is locked into its
own configuration that means the
gtp-bound state since the G alpha
subunit is locked into its own state now
huge amount of
psychic EMP would be produced and so the
downstream signaling would be also also
on for a long time this would result in
huge amount of protein kinase a
activation protein kinase a
phosphorylates CFTR a chloride ion
channel now opening of CFTR would allow
a huge amount of chloride ion loss now
due to this a B toxin a huge amount of
chloride ion is lost in the intestinal
lumen to compensate for this also water
is lost now water is lost from the
intestinal epithelium and also from the
blood vessels water is getting evacuated
that means huge amount of water is going
into the intestinal lumen and that is
causing the huge amount of diarrhea and
fluid loss from the body I hope you
enjoyed this video if you like my video
give it a thumbs up please don't forget
to subscribe and share thank you